Marc Pfeiffer laisse derrière lui le
souvenir d'un homme passionné depuis
l'annonce de sa mort les hommages se
multiplient comme celui de karlive
ancien maire de la commune tout passe
tous ces faces tu aurais pu attendre
hier soir tu es parti sans nous dire au
revoir on rêvait de Louis Chedid toi et
moi ou encore Sandrine bernaudo Santos
l'actuel maire le théâtre Molière perd
un directeur remarquable qui avait su
insuffler sa passion à toute une équipe
une minute de silence suivie d'une
minute d'applaudissement ont également
été respectées par le public du théâtre
dont il était directeur depuis 2015
sa passion pour le spectacle commence en
1978 avec une bande de copains Marc
Pfeiffer organise des concerts sur une
péniche amarrée à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine 10 ans plus
tard il lance l'Estival un festival de
musique indépendante plusieurs jeunes
talons font alors la première partie
d'artistes de Renaud comme Eddy Mitchell
Jimmy Cliff ou encore Johnny Cleg moi
j'étais à la création de ce festival
donc
l'évolution elle est bien entendu très
importante puisque on était plus sur
Saint-Germain à une époque puis on a
ouvert vers d'autres villes et là on
ouvre vers d'autres villes encore plus
sa compagne Maryline Boisselier et ses
fils Victor et Robin du rendent hommage
à travers une lettre Marc Pfeiffer homme
au mille vies né au Cameroun ardent
défenseur de la chanson francophone
toujours prêt à relever les défis les
plus fondateur et ancien président de la
Fédération des fest pas mal de chansons
francophones fait des chansons directeur
du Théâtre de Poissy depuis 2015 il
savait faire rayonner l'art vivant sous
toutes ses formes car vivant il l'était
passionnément éternellement Marc
Pfeiffer s'est éteint à l'âge de 64 ans
dans la nuit du jeudi 26 au vendredi 27
janvier